cities in Southwest Florida are now
directly in hurricane murmurs paths
catastrophic storm surge is a major
threat up and down the coast it could
reach 10 to 15 feet in Southwest Florida
Jonathan Vigliotti is in Naples where
the I will pass this afternoon Jonathan
good morning and Charlie good morning
we're expecting wind gusts to reach 135
miles per hour right now it's about 28
miles per hour sustained but as you
mentioned it really is that storm surge
for here in Naples and this West Coast
that's the big concern and really could
be the big killer we're here along the
Gulf that water 510 possibly 15 feet of
wall of water more than twice my height
coming from here and also from the bay
more east of where we were I want to
kind of show you come with me where all
of that water wind up going Naples is
only about three feet above sea level
that is not a lot of clearance and along
this coast there are thousands of homes
the only barrier protecting these homes
are these sand dunes right now some of
this covered by brush two feet so that
much of a barrier at all that water will
come through here again keep in mind
we're talking about something that could
be at the lower scale six feet around my
height possibly twice my height coming
up through here this boardwalk as we now
enter into streets like this everywhere
you go here in Naples our communities
like this so what does this water what
will this wall of water twice my height
look like you have cars here
police here they will be completely
covered they could be covered and you
have homes here that could also be
completely covered why so many people
are being told to evacuate that is
really descriptive reporting Jonathan
he's absolutely right just beyond that
boardwalk are many single level homes
beach homes you know beautiful homes
right there by the beach that are really
in danger of this storm surge that could
reach up to 15 feet according to
officials Thank You Jonathan we will
check back in with you